When we first looked up to the stars, we couldn’t
help but imagine what might live there, yet,
so far, we have found nothing.
When we first looked down into a microscope
though, well, we found more than we could
ever have guessed.
Let’s pretend that you and I are among the
earliest viewers of microbes, peering through
a tiny piece of crafted glass set into a brass
plate.
And, through that lens, we see a world that
is both entirely new, and unknowably ancient.
And as we look, still in the earliest days
of charting this landscape, of cataloging
strange organisms that defy or blur the classifications
of plant or animal.
We see, among those myriad, mysterious creatures—those bejeweled diatoms and charming rotifers that
make up our initial glimpses of the microcosmos—an
ensemble of blue or green trumpets: large
compared to many of the other organisms we
see, their elongated bodies adorned in rows
and rows of little hairs.
It’s that horn shape that will end up identifying
them not just by sight, but by name: Stentor,
for the herald of the Greek troops during
the Trojan War whose voice was said to carry
with the strength of fifty men.
Of course, our tools and understanding of
microbes have come a long way since those
first microscopic investigations, making it
possible for us to share this footage of our
own observations with you.
Recently, outside Warsaw, James found a small
pond in the middle of a forest that is filled
with microbes.
That pond has given us more Stentors to collect
and film, which means it’s also provided
us with an excuse to check in again on our favorite under-appreciated organisms of the microcosmos.
After all, Stentor’s voice carried through
millennia, but the legend of the microbial
Stentor seems more muted across the centuries
compared with some of the more studied ciliates.
But modern scientific tools are giving us
a new appreciation for Stentors.
But before we get there, we should note that
it’s not like Stentors have never held any
fascination for scientists.
As we talked about in our last Stentor-focused
episode, these single-celled organisms have
a complex body and an incredible capacity
for regeneration.
That regeneration process mirrors some of
the steps that drive the development of animal
embryos, making Stentors a compelling object
of study all the way through the mid-20th century.
But research is as much about the practicalities
as it is about exciting questions and implications.
And for many scientists, Stentors were simply
not the right choice for their experiments.
They were difficult to grow, and, in part
because of their tremendous size, they couldn’t
be used in the same experimental set-ups that
other organisms were more amenable to.
And so other ciliates that were easier to
work with, like paramecium, went on to become
more popular model protozoa, teaching us through
the lens of their own single-celled eukaryotic bodies.
But Stentors weren’t forgotten, they were
just awaiting the right tools.
We here work with the basics: forest ponds,
a microscope, and yes hundreds of hours spent
checking on our Stentors.
And we still manage to find them in incredible
situations.
This little ciliate pulls and pulls at the
stentor’s membrane until it just…erupts.
You can see the bead-like nuclei pouring out
of the Stentor along with the food vacuoles
and the rest of the cytoplasm, the inside
of its body now scattered around it.
And yet…for all the damage that is inflicted
on this Stentor, it survives.
It’s one thing to know that Stentors are
capable of this kind of regeneration, another
thing altogether to witness its survival in
real time on our slides.
This regenerative capacity, their shape, their
color, their size, the fact that they are
single-celled organisms, all of those factors
make it seem like we must not have much in
common with Stentors.
And if we were just reliant on what we could
see, we might still believe that.
But with the ongoing development of new genetic
tools, it’s the thing we’ve discovered
that we share in common with Stentors, and
that actually renders them distinct from much
of their brethren, that has given our trumpet
friends a new role in the study of the microscopic world.
When it comes to genetics, we often think
of DNA as a universal code...this is the simple
story that we’re taught in biology class.
Three base-pair sequences of DNA code for
amino acids to be added onto a protein over
and over until a gene ending code is reached
and the protein is complete.
And those codes that decide what amino acid
is added onto the protein, well, we’re taught
that that is a universal thing.
It is not.
There is what we call the standard code, the
one that we, and all multicellular organisms use.
And then there are others where letters change,
and punctuation becomes words, and most of
these are bacterial or mitochondrial code.
But especially among eukaryotes, ciliates
are noted genetic eccentrics due to their
tendency to take some of the sequences that,
in our code, signal the end of a gene, and
interpret them as coding for yet more amino
acids to stack onto the protein.
Different ciliate lineages have evolved their
own versions of this altered interpretation,
but there are only a few ciliates that have
been thought to follow the standard genetic
code that the rest of us do and Stentors are one of them.
And with recent genetic techniques probing
the sequences of Stentor coeruleus, that strange
conformity has now been confirmed.
Usually, when we bring up genetic studies
of microbes on this channel, they raise questions
about the details of classification schemes.
In the case of Stentors though, they raise
a deeper question: why do they resemble us
in this way, and why don’t the vast majority
of other ciliates?
If Stentor coeruleus follows the standard
genetic code, does that mean the original
ciliate also did?
And if so, then does that mean the nonstandard
genetic codes exhibited by so many ciliates
now are not some property inherent to the
phylum, but a product of an evolutionary path
that started after the Stentor family began
to branch away, a very very long time ago?
Evolution is weird and messy.
It is a knot that sometimes seems to become
more tangled the more we try to unravel it.
And Stentors, well, they’re confirmation
that no matter how simple something may seem—whether
it’s their own surprisingly complex single-celled
bodies or the supposed universality of the
genetic code—it only takes a few “what’s”,
“why’s,” and “how’s” to find yourself
enmeshed in a web of questions that is not
unlike the marvelous mysteries first uncovered
by the original microbe hunters hundreds of
years ago.
Their discoveries were world changing, but
so are ours.
We live in a time of great knowing, of great
uncovering, but that has also helped us realize
how many mysteries we have yet to solve.
Thank you for coming on this journey with
us as we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
If you would like to get a pin celebrating
the majesty of this peculiar organism, we
have Stentor coeruleus pins available now.
There’s a link in the description.
And also thank you so much to all of our patrons
on Patreon who allow us to continue these
explorations and keep our eyes out for more
bizarre happenings in our microscopes.
Without people like this, the work we’re
doing here on Journey to the Microcosmos would
not be possible.
So if you’re able to potentially join them,
that would be amazing.
And thank you to all of the people on this
list.
If you want to see more from our Master of
Microscopes, James, you can check out Jam
& Germ’s on Instagram.
And if you want to see more from us, here
at Journey to the Microcosmos, you can find
us at youtube.com/microcosmos.